there are a ton of practical machine
learning and data science or deep
learning projects that you can give a
crack at home even if you're working
with low powered devices like a
Raspberry Pi one of my absolute
favorites is drowsiness detection this
is super relevant particularly for the
logistics industry to do it you can use
an open source model like YOLO to detect
facial cues and from there determine if
there's signs of weariness prevailing
but if you're trying to get fit what's
another project that you can hit you can
build your very own gym tracker using
posenet in this case it's built using
Python scikit-learn opencv and tkinter
to build out a UI the model shown allows
you to count your gym reps but can be
easily extended for other workouts or
form tracking and last but certainly not
least you can teach AI to play games
using reinforcement learning this one's
a little bit more advanced but
definitely worth spending some time
doing here you can see an open AI gym
model learning to play Mario those are
just a couple that you can check out
there's a whole wide world out there